today we honor the men and women who
bravely gave their lives
for our country services were held
across the state including
at the southern nevada veterans memorial
cemetery this is in boulder city
reporter kate houston spoke to families
who are honoring the lives
that were lost
rows of american flags have been placed
to honor our fallen veterans
family members here tell me it meant
everything to have in-person services
again
hundreds of people came out monday
afternoon to pay their respects to the
men and women who gave the ultimate
sacrifice
family members community members active
military and politicians were all on
hand for the in-person service
the ceremony featured a flyover the
playing of taps and speeches about the
importance of this day
[Music]
following last year's cancellations due
to the pandemic
family members say it was impactful to
see the turnout
it's very emotional i miss my godfather
very much it's been
27 years if it wasn't for them we
wouldn't have the freedom we have today
and so many people don't understand that
they need to realize that you know
their sacrifices for was for us
the service lasted for about 25 minutes
the nevada department of veterans
services says this was to ensure covet
19 protocols were being followed
kate houston 8 news now